je saisis cette occasion pour vous
indiquer que l'attention de notre
commission sur ce sujet devrait se
prolonger dans les semaines et les mois
à venir puisque le bureau de notre
commission a décidé la création d'une
mission d'information sur les jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de paris
2024 qui devraient prochainement
commencer ses travaux
je vous propose maintenant de vous céder
la parole pour une dizaine de minutes
chacun je crois que vous avez préparé
les d un visuel à nous a commenté
et puis ensuite je laisserai la parole
bien sûr un chacun de nos collègues en
commençant par nous rappelle notre
rapporteur budgétaire jean jacques
lozach il vous posera une première série
de questions je vous cède la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs chers sénatrices
et sénateurs merci vraiment de votre
présence aujourd'hui merci de vous
intéresser à ce projet par et 2024
je dois dire que ce soutien
et permanent depuis le début même de la
candidature et cet effort important que
depuis son initiative ce projet puisse
être soutenue par les élus de la nation
je crois que nous avons collectivement
supporter une ambition pour la france
ce projet dépasse de très loin un projet
de sport c'est un vrai projet de société
nous avons une ambition effectivement de
de ne pas être juste et les trente
troisième jeu de l'histoire mais de
démontrer que la france est à l'origine
d'un projet d'un nouveau genre proposer
un nouveau modèle de jeu avec plus de
sobriété avec notre capacité à être
aussi innovant pour faire bouger les
lignes autour du sport autour de
l'engagement autour de l'impact sur les
territoires et potentiellement aussi
notre capacité à démontrer que le sport
dans ce pays a peu apporté un vrai
impact et répondre à des préoccupations
que se posent nos français en matière de
santé en matière d'éducation en matière
de lien social
nous avons cette conviction que le sport
est un vrai outil au service des
français et que ce projet qui est le
plus grand projet sportif mais même tous
domaines confondus que la france ait
jamais organisée peut être un vrai
accélérateur pour faire bouger les
lignes
et c'est donc fondamental que vous nous
aidiez que vous soyez connecté autant
que possible à ce projet et monsieur le
président je voulais vraiment commencer
par vous remercier pour pour cette
audition
alors effectivement juste en quelques
minutes avant de répondre plus
précisément à vos questions revenir
quand même sur l'essence même de ce
projet pour que chacune et chacun
d'entre vous puisse bien maîtrisé ce
qu'on est en train de mettre en place
aujourd'hui avec paris 2024 donc si on
passe sur la slide suivante
je ne sais pas voilà alors les jeux en
quelques chiffres très rapidement c'est
le plus grand événement sportif
on va accueillir quinze mille athlètes
qui viendront de 206 pays
au programme des jeux olympiques 32
sport 28 +4 sport additionnelles que
nous avons souhaité rajouter pour
essayer de rajeunir encore notre notre
audience et puis vint de sport pour les
jeux paralympiques
c'est à dossier à 7 ce plus grand
événement sportif la plus grande
plateforme de communication on a cette
opportunité aujourd'hui alors bien
évidemment on s'est positionné avant de
cette crise sanitaire mais quelque part
utilisant la plateforme de communication
que sont ces jeux qui sera regardé par 4
milliards de personnes ce sont les
chiffres des derniers jeux on va
accueillir vingt mille journalistes un
programme de volontaires de 50000
personnes à travers bien évidemment un
programme de recrutement sur tout le
pays
et puis un programme de billetterie très
important 13 millions et demi de
spectateurs le plus grand événement en
nombre de spectateurs que nous aurons
jamais organisé et un parcours du relais
de la flamme qui je suis sûr vous
intéresse puisqu'il va traverser dans
les trois mois qui précéderont la
cérémonie d'ouverture
l'ensemble de notre territoire si on
continue peut être un mot sur le budget
ou vous l'avez dit monsieur le président
c'est aussi un engagement très fort de
paris 2024 de proposer un nouveau modèle
de financement de jeu avec un budget qui
aujourd'hui est financé à plus de 97%
par le secteur privé 3 milliards 900
millions d'euros
avec trois grands tiers de financement
un premier tiers qui est apportée par le
cio lui même un deuxième tiers qui est
apportée par notre programme billetterie
et effectivement quelques produits
dérivés et un troisième tiers financé
par les entreprises partenaires de paris
c'est important de le souligner ici
parce que quelque part nous aurons la
capacité d'investir le comité
d'organisation est une association de
droit privé vous l'avez vu financé
principalement par de l'argent privé
puisque 100% du modèle économique des
jeux olympiques est financé par de
l'argent privé
il y a une contribution d'argent public
sur un concours public vous voyez ici
200 millions d'euros qui est fléché
directement sur les jeux paralympiques
puisque pour les jeux paralympiques il
n'y a pas de contribution du comité
international paralympique al'inverse du
cio qui lui a abondé à hauteur d'un
tiers de notre budget donc à une une
contribution d'argent public sur les sur
les jeux paralympiques alors maintenant
la réussite de parler de 1024 pour nous
elle réside dans trois grands défis
le premier des filles je les cite avant
de les deux les dérouler peut-être le
premier défi c'est effectivement de
réussir une célébration spectaculaire
ouverte et responsables dont je vais y
revenir dans un instant le deuxième défi
ce sera de construire en héritage
collectif pour que encore une fois la
place du sport dans ce pays puisse jouer
un rôle plus important au service de la
société et notre troisième défi c'est
notre capacité à engager l'ensemble des
français des territoires dans la
réussite de cet événement qui fera date
cela fait cent ans que l'on n'a pas
organiser les jeux olympiques d'été et
ce seront les premiers jeux
paralympiques que le nôtre pays
organisera alors maintenant si je
déroule très rapidement sur les trois
défis sur le premier défi effectivement
pour la célébration on a cette chance de
pouvoir capitaliser sur des sites
iconique qui ont déjà vont me démontrer
fait leurs preuves à travers de grands
événements donc bien évidemment c'est le
cas pour le stade de france
si on continue on se rend compte que on
a aussi cette chance de pouvoir utiliser
la plateforme des jeux pour révéler
quelque part notre plus beau patrimoine
et c'est ça aussi la magie de ce projet
c'est de réussir à associer le sport et
la culture de réussir à proposer des
émotions très fortes pour les athlètes
mais aussi pour les spectateurs et
surtout pour les 4 milliards de
personnes qui vont regarder ces jeux à
la télévision de se dire waouh
quand même c'est beau et donc nous
aurons des épreuves
au pied de la tour eiffel aux invalides
place de la concorde dans les jardins du
château de versailles et même vous
l'avez vu à tahiti j'imagine que
peut-être que nous y reviendrons mais
c'était important pour nous à la fois
d'allier les meilleures conditions
sportives et il se trouve que la plus
belle vague du monde elle est française
elle est à tahiti à cette période de
l'année et donc nous souhaitions
effectivement pouvoir associer ce
territoire la réussite des jeux les
épreuves de voile et de football à
marseille
et ça aussi c'est important pour nous le
deuxième défi c'est celui de l'héritage
alors en matière d'héritage pour nous il
ya deux grands objectifs
le premier objectif c'est de changer le
modèle on veut des jeux plus sobre on
veut des jeux qui divise par deux les
émissions carbone d'une organisation
olympique
c'est sans précédent ça veut dire qu'on
va s'appuyer sur 95% en infrastructures
déjà existantes ou temporaires qu'on va
desservir l'ensemble des sites de
compétition par des transports en commun
pour vraiment avoir un impact
significatif sur
le modèle écologique de ces jeux est le
modèle financier parce que forcément
chaque euro dépensé
le sera au service
deux projets et de création d'un pacte
est donc la deuxième dimension de
l'héritage pour nous c'est avant de
parler d'engagement c'est encore une
fois comment réussir à positionner le
sport comme un outil au service de la
population et nous avons des ambitions
très forte pour réussir à ce que les
français fassent plus d'activité
physique aujourd'hui malheureusement les
statistiques ne sont pas très bonnes
dans notre pays on se rend compte que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
révélé que 85% des jeunes ne pratiquent
pas assez d'activités physiques que un
jeune sur cinq est en situation de
surpoids et d'obésité et donc des
statistiques de sédentarité qui continue
d'augmenter alors que 30 minutes
d'activité physique quotidienne a un
impact direct et significatif à la fois
sur la santé mais aussi sur le bien-être
et sur la concentration pour l'école et
ainsi de suite donc on veut vraiment
réussir à mobiliser l'ensemble des
forces en présence pour réussir à
collectivement trouver des voies de
passage pour faire faire plus d'activité
physique à la population française dès
le plus jeune âge parce que pour nous
les bonnes habitudes doivent être prises
quelque part dès le plus jeune âge et
notamment à l'école à l'école primaire
et c'est pour ça que avec le ministère
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports
nous prenons cette mesure de 30 minutes
d'activité physique quotidienne mais on
pourra y revenir dans un instant
notamment avec marie barsacq qui
m'accompagne aujourd'hui qui est la
directrice exécutive de paris du 24 en
charge de l'héritage et de l'impact
le troisième défi c'est celui de
l'engagement de tous
là aussi nous avons réussi à faire
bouger les lignes à faire accepter par
le cio
la création d'un label qui s'appelle
terre de jeux 2024 qui permet à
l'ensemble des territoires qui croient
aux sports qui ont envie de faire partie
de ce dynamique des jeux de pouvoir être
labellisé une terre de jeux 2024 et de
déployer les différents programmes de
paris 2024 encore une fois dans les
écoles dans les quartiers réussi à
rapprocher ce monde associatif
et les collectivités locales parce que
le sport français et j'en suis un bon
témoin aujourd'hui repose sur une
dynamique sur l'ensemble du territoire
les grands champions français viennent
des quatre coins de la france ils ont
commencé le sport dans des petites
structures associatives soutenu par les
collectivités locales
et c'est très important qu'on arrive à
valoriser cette dynamique locale dans
l'ensemble des territoires à travers ce
projet par une 1024 et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on est plutôt heureux
alors que ce programme à moins de 2 a
été lancé cette idée a été lancée il ya
moins de deux ans maintenant d'avoir
déjà 25 millions de français qui vivent
dans une collectivité terre de jeux 2024
et qui du coup ont accès à un certain
nombre de programmes le dernier mot pour
moi ce sera à vous dire aussi que pour
les français
effectivement nous avons créé un club
paris 2024 qui est un club accessible à
tous gratuit bien évidemment et qui
permet juste en s'inscrivant sur ce club
paris 1024 d'être destinataire de
l'ensemble des informations pour savoir
comment devenir volontaire savoir
comment s'engager dans l'aventuré
comment rencontrer des grands champions
on a déjà organisé un certain nombre de
défis autour dé tony parker teddy riner
florent manaudou et les plus grands
champions français qui régulièrement
donne rendez vous alors à leurs fans
pour partager la préparation des jeux de
paris 2024 et pour aller au bout de
cette ouverture de ces jeux de paris
2024 nous avons souhaité même ouvrir la
participation du grand public à quelques
épreuves pendant les jeux ce sera le cas
notamment du marathon qui sera
accessible à l'ensemble des français qui
souhaitent y participer mais on fera
aussi la même chose pour les épreuves de
cyclisme donc vous le voyez ce projet
est très ambitieux malgré le contexte
aujourd'hui on continue à porter cette
ambition parce que ce projet plus que
jamais offre un horizon positif pour
pour ce pays
on va mobiliser 150 mille emplois
directement dans l'organisation de ces
jeux vous l'avez vu 4 milliards à peu
près 4 milliards d'euros d'argent privé
réinjecter dans l'économie française
aussi dans l'est dans les prochaines
années
et c'est surtout une formidable
opportunité de réussir à valoriser le
rôle et la place du sport dans le
quotidien des français et c'est pour
cela que nous avons besoin que chacun
prenne sa part de responsabilité et et
nous avons besoin de votre soutien
voilà monsieur le président est bien
évidemment je serai à votre totale
disposition pour répondre aux questions
et peut-être je donne la parole je vous
rends la parole merci merci monsieur le
président ils sont plus tarder je donne
la parole donc être un monsieur ferrand
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs alors quelques
j'ai une petite présentation si on peut
afficher comme introduction donc je vais
vous parler des ouvrages en titre de ce
qu'on est à construire de manière
pérenne pour pouvoir accueillir le grand
événement dont le tony estanguet vous à
d'adresser les grands contours enfin ses
alliés vous d'après donc là nous
existons sa maladie peut couper vous
pouvez avoir la diapo complexe que j'ai
est celle là nous n'avons qu'une image
après nous allons du texte voilà donc il
ya 37 mois la suite et ont été créées en
janvier 2018 alors la seule vidéo
s'inscrit peut-être bientôt d'après s'il
vous plaît dans une organisation pour
livrer les jeux que je vous rappelle en
quelques mots on a en gros trois grandes
structures on a le cojo qui va
effectivement organiser l'événement
lui-même 3 milliards 9 dont tony
estanguet vous a parlé à une association
on a là ces vidéos donc établissements
publics
un budget de 3 milliards 2 en valeur
2016 et j'y reviendrai à parité publics
et privés qui en charge de livres et de
garantir que tous les ouvrages
nécessaires pour les jeux seront livrés
dans les délais conformément au
programme nécessaire pour les jeux et
que ces ouvrages auront une deuxième vie
après les jeux c'est dire que la leur
transformation à l'issue des jeux sera
garantie et donc ça c'est la soli deo la
présidence du conseil des migrations l'a
suivi des eaux étant annuel go et plus
on a tous les acteurs de l'héritage donc
de héritage immatériel et enfin on
allait
job délégation interministérielle aux
jeux olympiques qui est là pour faire
fonctionner l'ensemble du dispositif
donc michel cadot aujourd'hui jean
castex pressé d'avoir un diapo d'après
alors sur ce qui concerne les ouvrages
pérenne donc les ouvrages sur qui on est
et dont la réalisation a été confiée à
la soli deo
vous avez vu le concept des jeux a
évolué les fondamentaux pour nous n'ont
pas changé depuis 37 mois
on a ajouté un certain nombre d'objets
il ya 37 ans n'étaient sur 40 objets
aujourd'hui on l'a 62 objets pérenne à
livrer dont les plus gros les plus
emblématiques plus visible le village
olympique le centre aquatique olympique
la marina de marseille par exemple mais
aussi on a rajouté un certain nombre
d'objets plus petits à une nouvelle base
de pompiers de police quatorze
rénovation de sites d'entraînement des
objets qu'ils n'étaient pas encore
identifiées
il ya trente sept mois et est
aujourd'hui sont nécessaires pour la
bonne réalisation des jeux donc soixante
deux objets aujourd'hui le reste des
fondamentaux est inchangé est ce qu'il
est possible d'avoir l'intégralité de la
diapositive parce que vous le bas est
coupée jeu confus or le bas est
important si les données financières
sont en bas excusez moi voilà donc 60
des objets
le montant de subventions publiques le
montant de subventions publiques qui
était un milliard trois cent soixante
dix huit
il ya trois ans et globalement a changé
puisqu'on en est un milliard trois cent
quatre-vingt-six sont les choix en euro
2016 donc on a cette question ensuite
d'indexer en euros courants mais le
montant de subventions publiques est
inchangé et on est dans une histoire où
l'essentiel des investissements
l'essentiel des objets que vous avoir
réalisé sont en seine-saint-denis
puisque les trois quarts 75 % des
subventions publiques et 44 objets
seront réalisés en seine-saint-denis la
diapositive d'après s'il vous plaît
la très grande singularité de
l'organisation des jeux en france c'est
que la solide et on ne fait pas tout la
seo l'ideo s'appuie sur les
collectivités territoriales pour que
elles construisent les différents objets
nécessaires pour les jeux sous la
supervision de la souys déroulera ainsi
par exemple la ville de paris construit
l'aréna deux sous la supervision de la
soul idéaux et avec le financement la
solide et au donc on est dans une
histoire où on à 72 ouvrage pyrène 29
maître d'ouvragé a plein 13 cofinanceurs
ça on est dans une histoire classique et
donc on a ce râteau et une seconde
encore s'il vous plaît voilà et toute la
halle à la fois la difficulté de cette
aventure là c'est de coordonner ces 29
maître d'ouvragé pour que tous les
ouvrages soient livrés à temps et le a
tant et tant le 31 décembre 2000 23 de
manière à ce que le cojo puisse les
prendre en main les tester les habillés
aux couleurs olympiques pendant le
premier semestre 2010 24 et que à l'été
2000 24 tout soit parfait pour
accueillir la famille et mazamet
olympiques les athlètes les journalistes
et les spectateurs
yapo d'après alors où en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui le planning que je vous
montre c'est le planning nous avions
posé il ya trois ans qui est aujourd'hui
inchangée nous avions indiqué ya trois
ans que les trois premières années de
vie la solide et au donc 2018 2019 2020
seraient les années de conception des
ouvrages de l'acquisition du foncier et
d'obtention de l'ensemble des
autorisations administratives et
qu'ensuite les années 21 22 23 seraient
les années de travaux de construction
des différents ouvrages aujourd'hui
malgré de confinement on parlera du
troisième confinement après malgré la
crise la crise sanitaire nous sommes
exactement dans le calendrier que nous
avions posé quand je dis nous c'est à la
fois la solide et odense qu'elle réalise
en propre et puis l'ensemble des 28
autres maîtres d'ouvragé dans ce qu'ils
réalisent de coin nous sommes exactement
dans le calendrier posé il ya trois ans
c'est important de le redire ça veut
dire que nous nous commençons les
travaux et j'y viendrai dans ma dernière
diapositives mais ça veut dire que nous
avons du temps et ayant du temps nous
pouvons absorber les allées à la crise
du coc vie pour autant qu'elle ne se
prolonge pas plusieurs années des aléas
climatiques importants nous et nous
avons intégré dans notre planning de
travaux sans être obligé de passer en
deux victoires en trois huit donc ça on
s'en passait à rythme accéléré la
capacité d'absorber le monde réel les
risques qui pourraient se présenter
ce qui veut dire que aujourd'hui les
enveloppes financières que nous avons
prévu devrait suffire parce que nous
n'avons pas besoin aux joueurs à jour
par là aujourd'hui d'accélérer ou
d'envisager d'accélérer les travaux
alors un petit point
diapo d'après s'il vous plaît un petit
peu alors on avait trois trois
dimensions qui nous étaient posées au
delà de la seule livraison des ouvrages
pour paris 2024 derrière cette question
qu'est ce qui se joue sur c'est sur ces
ouvrages pérenne on a évidemment une
question d' accélération des termes de
dynamique métropolitaine et
singulièrement dans cette partie de la
seine saint denis à la limite avec les
hauts-de-seine où avec l'arrivée du
stade de france on a eu le premier étage
de la fusée le village olympique que et
l'ensemble des ouvrages un pic étant le
deuxième étage de la file est donc là on
a un sujet kim qui se développe et que
ceux qui envient délai prescrit des
passants videla derrière nous puisque
les travaux commencent on avait un
deuxième sujet qui nous était posée qui
est faire des jeux exemplaire tony
estanguet l'a rappelé on veut et le
gouvernement nous avait demandé d'avoir
des premiers ouvrages des premiers jeux
entièrement alignés sur les accords de
paris mais singulièrement sur le carbone
et enfin on a un troisième enjeu vous
savez que tout les métiers liés à la
ville sont des métiers dans lequel nous
avons des leaders mondiaux vinci premier
constructeur mondial bouygues le numéro
et et dans tout dans tout l'est dans
tous les champs y compris des champions
ne pourrait ignorer comme la météo la
météorologie urbaine météo france et à
le modèle le plus avancé au monde sur
les prévisions météo urbaine donc on a
dit aux mondiaux et on nous avait
demandé que les ouvrages un pic soit
l'occasion de mettre en avant de savoir
faire et d'innover dans les clients
reliés à la ville singulièrement il ya
peu d'après stocker singulièrement au
niveau environnemental
on nous avait demandé de travailler sur
cinq thématiques qu'ils soient très
différenciante parme par rapport aux
grands événements mondiaux que sont donc
les jeux de tokyo les jeux de pékin mais
également l'exposition universelle de
dubaï qui sont trois événements les
trois prochains événements ont duré donc
re re on nous a dit nous a demandé de
travailler sur cinq thématiques qui
pourrait différencier au savoir faire
industriel par rapport à ccc grand ces
grandes manifestations technologique
donc évidemment le carbone et on a à
travers les ouvrages à un pic on va
atteindre - 45 % du bilan carbone en
construction la ddd 2021 ce qui était ce
qui veut dire que dans l'économie de la
seine-saint-denis dans une économie
immobilière dans une économie la
construction classique parce que on est
dans des dans une économie normale on
peut dès maintenant atteindre moins 45%
sur le bilan carbone c'est-à-dire avoir
dix ans d'avancé sur la stratégie
nationale bas carbone c'est ça ce qu'on
est en train de démontrer
on nous a demandé d'avoir un des
dispositifs de bâtiments qui soit
adaptée au climat 2050 c'est-à-dire le
moment où l'été standard connaissent que
correspondre à la canicule de 2003 et
nous le faisons nous a demandé de
travailler sur la biodiversité urbaine
alors là c'est un sujet sur lequel on
est moins avancé que sur les deux
premiers qui est un des enjeux que nous
avons maintenant nous a demandé
travailler sur l'économie circulaire et
nous réutilisons 92% de tous ou de tout
ce qui existe physiquement sur le
village olympique donc le village
olympique lorsque nous avons pris les
terrains c'était une zone industrielle
nous avons re déconstruit et recycler
92% en masse de tous qui étaient
présents y compris les faux plafonds les
moquettes le
le lot mobilier tout 92 % c'est un
chiffre qui n'a jamais été atteint
jusqu'à présent et puis sur
l'accessibilité universelle le madame
cluzel nous a demandé et nous nous qui
nous suit très très près nous a demandé
de travailler sur la logique du
vieillissement de la population
c'est à dire non pas le handicap lourd
mais la somme vous savez des petites
difficultés que nos aînés peuvent avoir
et qui rendent la vie compliquée en
ville voilà donc comment est ce qu'on
peut penser l'accessibilité finalement
une forme de ville bienveillante en
mettant à bout une somme de petites
solutions autour de ça diapo d'après et
puis on nous a également demandé de
répondre à trois grands objectifs
le premier objectif c'est que les jeux
soient est un vecteur de dynamisme pour
l'emploi des gens qui sont loin de
l'emploi et donc que 10 % 10 % des
heures travaillées sur l'ensemble des
ouvrages olympiques soient réservés à
des publics point de l'emploi alors 10%
ces deux fois le volume demandé
classiquement sur les opérations en rue
inversement ce qui a été proposé c'est
qu'on élargisse l'assiette c'est à dire
que ça ne soit pas simplement les
chômeurs de longue durée et les plus les
l'entrain jean fois mais également les
apprentis les alternants et la
discrimination à l'adresse aujourd'hui
ça veut dire qu'on va faire on va dans
le cas des ouvrages olympique
aujourd'hui on va réaliser près de 0,4
million d'heures d'insertion
on est au début des grands chantiers
donc on suit ça on en est aujourd'hui à
180 mineurs dont on est encore petit par
rapport à cet objectif de 2 4 millions
mais on est au début les chantiers c'est
au moins des chantiers de choses se
passent plus qu au moment des études et
puis on nous a également demandé que 25%
en valeur des marchés soient dédiés à
des pme des tpe des structures de l'ess
alors aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble de tous
les maîtres d'ouvragé passant plan
solide et aux messageries hotmail ou
rage près de 750 millions d'euros de
marchés publics et privés ont été passés
750 millions d'euros le marché et le 20
juin ouvert du 2 % de ces marchés ont
été passés auprès de pme tpe structure
de ss ça fait presque
et ça fait près 150 millions et ça que
ça concerne 620 pme partout en france
alors on vous a pas mis la carte pour
pas alourdir les doigts mais c'est
extraordinaire c'est là qu'on a
aujourd'hui
cet effet de diffusion de la dynamique
des ouvrages à un pic qui mobilise près
plus de 600 pme y compris dans décodant
dans des zones très reculées comme le
morvan voilà et puis il ya peu après où
en sommes nous de deux derniers points
pour ouvrir le question vous pourriez
avoir dire que d'après s'il vous plaît
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut vraiment vous dire c'est que tous
les gros ouvrages ont achevé leur
conception et ont récupéré toutes leurs
autorisations administratives
le village olympique que vous avez
larmes on a révélé le village avec s'il
vous plaît à tout le monde il a rappelé
que le village et médias le centre la
piscine olympique réalisé par la
métropole du grand paris le l'aréna 2
réalisé par la ville de paris
la marina de marseille les pins
construire a été déposé elle n'est pas
venue de marseille donc tous les gros
ouvrage structurant aujourd'hui ont
achevé leur conception et donc on va
passer en phase travaux
est ce qu'on est en train de finir de
concevoir c'est tout ce qui est
rénovation de sites existants et
qu'est-ce qui ce jeu qu'est ce qui se
prépare pour 2021
peut-être à dire que d'après merci
beaucoup c'est vraiment la phase de
lancement des grands chantiers donc en
janvier il y avait un chantier est lancé
en mars on en a quatre
à la fin de l'année on aura 32 chantier
qui est trente deux ouvrages en chantier
sur les 62 sert tous les plus gros sera
en chantier singulièrement l'ensemble du
village olympique sera en chantier le
village olympique
à la fin de l'année ses 4000 salariés
donc à cheval entre saint-ouen
saint-saint-denis et l'île saint denis
4000 salariés mobilisés ce sera le plus
grand chantier monocytes de france donc
c'est ça ce qui est en train de se
lancer 40 grue en 2021 ses 750 millions
d'euros de travaux donc publics et
privés tourne à tous les promoteurs
construisent les bâtiments sur les 750
millions d'euros de travaux on a 2 76
millions
de subventions publiques une part de
l'état une part des collectivités 9000
salariés au total mobilisés quatre
ministres village olympique 5000 sur les
autres ouvrages
alors évidemment évidemment c'est un
accélérateur de la reprise de la relance
dans le dans les conditions dans lequel
on est et ça pose beaucoup de questions
sur lequel on travaille avec beaucoup
d'énergie sur l'insertion et sur les
conditions de travail puisque même si on
a du temps sur les chantiers on sait que
cette concentration humaine sur les
chantiers avec un calendrier une
pression extrêmement forte et ne doit
pas se faire au détriment de la sécurité
des travailleurs voient là monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ce que je pouvais vous dire en
introduction
si monsieur le directeur général sans
plus tarder je venais parole à jean
jacques lozach qui est le rapporteur
budgétaire des crédits sport et qui va
vous poser une première cette issue oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président du cojep cher tony estanguet
ce directeur général exécutif de la
solide et aux quelques questions oui
pour introduire nos débats de ce matin
tout à l'heure ce président vous avez
évoqué l'héritage l'héritage olympique
héritage durable diversifié qui n'est
pas effectivement simplement une
capacité à organiser un événement ou
bien gagner un certain nombre de
médailles mais également beaucoup
d'autres choses et en particulier le
développement des pratiques dans notre
pays et c'est vrai que un chiffrage très
ambitieux avait été annoncée par laura
flessel à l'époque est confirmée par le
président de la république c'est à dire
3 millions de pratiquants
supplémentaires alors ceci dit la
pandémie est passée par là et
malheureusement va encore sans doute
nous occuper au cours des mois qui
viennent et je voudrais
vous demandez est ce que le moment n'est
peut-être pas venue de poursuivre un
objectif un peu plus réaliste quoi si je
peux dire c'est à dire avoir un objectif
tout simplement de de revenir à la fin
de l'année 2019 de revenir effectivement
une période d'avant qu'ovide bon on veut
bien croire qu'il va y avoir une
frénésie d'activité physique au sortir
de ce de ce confinement
mais est-ce que effectivement il ne faut
pas évoquer aujourd'hui des objectifs un
petit peu à la baisse ce qui concerne le
développement du nombre de pratiquants
une deuxième question cette fois-ci sur
ton financier au mois de novembre
dernier on a été présenté une version je
dirais provisoire d'un rapport de la
cour des comptes qui évoquait en
particulier des surcoûts estimés à 400
millions d'euros notamment pour des
raisons de sécurité est-ce que vous
pouvez donner un petit peu de précisions
concernant ces surcoûts et bien sûr en
fait de ces surcoûts était envisagé une
économie analogues
c'est à dire une économie d'environ 400
millions d'euros est ce que payent donc
nous apporter quelques éléments
complémentaires sur ces chiffrages l'a
ensuite une question qui a trait
vraiment l'actualité parce qu'il ya une
petite étude qui est sorti la semaine
dernière de sport saura et qui vendent
que malheureusement contrairement à 2020
où les choses étaient plutôt pas trop
mal passé en matière de mécénat
d'entreprise et de sponsoring
il y a dors et déjà un recul pour
l'année 2000 21
non ça concerne peut-être pas du tout
les jezzy comme on dit les grands
événements sportifs internationaux
mais est-ce que vous avez des craintes
de ce côté là ce que la crise sanitaire
d'ores et déjà remis en question un
certain nombre de projets de partenariat
même ce même chose je dirais pour les
collectivités territoriales parce que
vous savez que la crise coûte beaucoup
d'argent collectivités territoriales
bons les chiffres qui sont annoncés
tourne autour de de 3,8 milliards
d'euros pour l'année 2020
est-ce que je dirais l'enthousiasmé
toujours au rendez vous bien ce que vous
avez là aussi quelques quelques craintes
quelques inquiétudes
et enfin je termine là dessus
je reviens petit peu sur le
développement de l'activité physique et
sportive dans l'établissement scolaire
puisque fin janvier vous avez lancé avec
le ministre blanc caire et la ministre
des sports c'est cette opération 30
minutes d'activité physique et sportive
quotidienne à l'école et pour nous je
dirais que c'est un petit peu floue
cette affaire alors c'est vrai que c'est
on est dans un contexte éducatif très
particulier non mais est ce que cette
campagne de 30 minutes supplémentaires
est ce que c'est pendant ce temps
scolaire hors temps scolaire quels sont
les personnels concernés que sont les
enseignants l'éducation nationale les
éducateurs sportifs des clubs les agents
des collectivités territoriales et
cetera qui financent et c'est ce qu'on
peut avoir des précisions sur ces 30
minutes qui normalement devraient venir
s'ajouter aux heures d'éducation
physique et sportive d'ores et déjà
prévues par les instructions officielles
je propose de répondre déjà ses
premières questions puis après on
enchaînera par d'autres questions merci
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
sénateur pour ces questions peut-être on
va commencer par répondre aux deux
questions
qui traitent sur l'héritage puis après
je répondrai plus sur les questions
budgétaires en matière de sécurité
notamment et de recherche de
partenariats peut-être marie barsacq
on va vous éclairer un petit peu sur les
30 minutes et moi je dirai un mot
éventuellement sur les 3 millions
pratiquant aussi très bien alors les 30
minutes
c'est effectivement un dispositif qui
est porté par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
à ce stade les écoles s'inscrivent de
façon volontaire à la mise en place de
cette expérimentation il ya aujourd'hui
1100 école qui expérimente le dispositif
c'est tout simplement la mise en place
tous les jours de 30 minutes d'activité
physique avec son enseignante dans la
cour de récréation
ça peut être en début de journée ça peut
être en milieu de journée ça peut être
l'après midi autour et récréation en
tout cas c'est un temps qui est sous
l'autorité de l'enseignant donc de
l'enseignant aménage sa journée de
travail en intégrant ces 30 minutes
d'activité physique
ces trente minutes vous l'avez dit sont
évidemment complémentaire à le ps pour
nous c'est un marchepied vers plus
d'éducation physique et sportive dans le
quotidien des enfants à l'école vous
savez que ces temps de ps ne sont sont
loin d'être respectées par tous il y a
des communes qui financent des
intervenants municipaux vous l'avez site
est donc là ces communes là les enfants
ont la chance d'avoir parfois trois
heures mais à paris par exemple c'est le
cas les enfants n'ont qu'une heure et
demie donc on est quand même loin des 3
heures et puis dans les communes où
c'est l'enseignant lui même qui porte le
ps on voit que l'enseignant privilégie
parce que les les recommandations
ministérielles sont très fortes sur le
lire écrire compter
et de fait le ps passe à la trappe quand
on manque de temps sur ces trois
matières et bien on va sucre et le ps
c'est comme ça qu'en france
donc nous on a conçu 7 6 ce dispositif
avec l'éducation nationale comme un
outil pour accélérer la place de le ps
et du sport scolaire dans l'enceinte de
l'école parce que ça nous semble
essentiel
on le sait vous savez les études sont
catastrophiques tonicité sur la
sédentarité des enfants c'est galopant
aujourd'hui quand même un enfant sur
cinq en situation d'obésité avant
l'entrée en 6ème c'est grave c'est
vraiment des adultes qui vont avoir des
pathologies lourdes
ça va peser évidemment sur les finances
de notre société mais ça pèse sur la vie
quotidienne de ces gens donc il faut
enrayer la mécanique et on sait les
médecins ont prouvé tout se joue entre 6
et 11 ans un enfant qui ne bouge pas
sera un adulte sédentaire donc il faut
agir à ce moment là il faut donner le
goût de bouger aux enfants pour qu'ils
aient envie de faire du sport de façon
régulière
donc notre idée c'est vraiment d'avoir
ce marchepied de 30 minutes qui va
donner envie de faire de la pêche aux
enseignants aussi parce qu'ils vont
prendre contrôle on se rendre compte
aussi des effets bénéfiques de ces
trente minutes
les études montrent tout aussi une
activité physique quotidienne favorise
la concentration des élèves c'est
important ça elle favorise aussi le
climat de classe un climat de classe
apaisée plus serein plus tranquille qui
permet un meilleur enseignement donc
pour toutes ces raisons considère que
c'est important
nous notre objectif il est plus large
que 30 minutes d'activité physique vous
imaginez bien c'est évidemment que les
enfants aillent vers les clubs c'est ça
notre objectif majeur mais on pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait cette étape
première d'une activité physique
quotidienne
à cet âge là c'est une heure par jour on
se dit que trente minutes c'est la
moitié du chemin parcouru dans le temps
scolaire
il reste encore le périscolaire les
parcs et puis la vie avec ses parents
pour faire les 30 autres minutes et puis
pour nous je finirai là dessus le
dispositif est extrêmement important
parce que on veut qu'ils aient que les
enfants jouent un rôle de prescripteur
aussi auprès de leurs parents en fait
toucher les enfants d'une certaine façon
et les éveiller à la nécessité d'être
actif tous les jours c'est aussi pour
nous une façon de convaincre les parents
de faire de même pour eux-mêmes et
d'accompagner leurs enfants au club pour
que les enfants les parents considèrent
qu effectivement 30 minutes c'est là
aussi un marchepied et qu'ils amènent
leurs enfants au club pour une activité
régulière
et que le sport en famille se pratiquent
de façon beaucoup plus large et que le
loisir soit beaucoup plus sportif qu'il
n'est aujourd'hui ce dispositif est
vraiment été pensé pour qu'ils
n'engendrent pas de dépenses
supplémentaires ce sont des contenus
pédagogiques clé en main qui sont
fournis aux professeurs des écoles avec
des fiches thématiques pour faire des
séances de 30 minutes autour de
apprendre à sauter apprendre à courir
apprendre à danser
voilà des choses assez simples et
ludiques qui permettent vraiment aux
enfants de se dépenser et que ce soit
facile à mettre en place sans matériel
nécessaire pour pour cesser en cela sur
la question des 3 millions de
pratiquants supplémentaires bon bien
évidemment c'est au gouvernement qui a
fixé cette ambition là nous on n'a pas à
commenter ce chiffre
moi à titre personnel je pense qu'il est
encore plus important aujourd'hui
qu'avant de considérer qu'on doit garder
de l'ambition là dessus et qu'on doit
trouver des solutions pour développer le
nombre de pratiquants sportifs dans
notre pays on parle pas là de forcément
de licenciés mais on parle de
pratiquants et moi je crois encore plus
qu'avant cette crise sanitaire qu'au
contraire il faut garder le cap de cette
ambition concernant les questions sur
les budgets donc vous avez mentionné le
rapport provisoire de la cour des
comptes nous attendons toujours le
rapport définitif qui devrait arriver
prochainement dans les prochaines
semaines qui effectivement a fait le
point c'est notre deuxième contrôle de
la cour des comptes nous avions déjà été
contrôlé après la phase de candidature
donc un premier rapport avait été écrit
et publié sur ce deuxième rapport
effectivement sur les coûts de sécurité
bombe nous on a procédé vous l'avez
mentionné également dans votre propos au
cours de l'année 2020 en fait dès le
début de la crise sanitaire nous avons
mobilisé l'ensemble des équipes de paris
me 24 pour affiner notre budget
pluri-annuel d'organisation livraison
des jeux en fait le 3 milliards 8 qui
avait été identifié en 2016
en pleine phase de candidature
nous avons repassé au peigne fin
l'ensemble des lignes budgétaires
bien évidemment tout ça a été contrôlée
par notamment les ministères des
finances et on a un certain nombre de
procédures en place pour construire nos
nos budgets et donc ce budget nouveau
budget pluriannuel qui nous a permis en
faisant effectivement de l'ordre de 300
millions d'euros d'économies en
réduisant le nombre de sites de
compétition on a réduit de quatre sites
au total le nombre d'infrastructures
pour réussir à organiser plus des
preuves puisque nous avons réussi à
inclure notamment les nouveaux sports
quatre sports ont été rajoutés par paris
d 1024 il ya un petit peu plus d'un an
et c'est sport là on a réussi à les
inclure dans ce nouveau budget sans
augmenter de manière significative
puisque en fait on a réussi à négocier
une contribution supplémentaire du cio
de l'ordre de 125 millions d'euros qui
nous a permis aujourd'hui d'avoir un
budget réévalué est validé par
l'ensemble des parties prenantes de
parts et demi de 24 qui inclut un
certain nombre de nouveaux coups donc
les nouveaux sports mais aussi henri
chiffrage de la sécurité que l'on a
augmenté à 300 millions d'euros puisque
on a un protocole de serre et de
sécurité qui a été signé avec les forces
là aussi et l'état qui permet d'affiner
la matrice de responsabilités en matière
de sécurité est effectivement paris 1024
prend à sa charge l'ensemble des moyens
de sécurité dans les enceintes sportives
pour assurer que toutes les personnes
qui viennent assister aux épreuves puis
centre en toute sécurité et les forces
de l'ordre continuent d'assurer la
sécurité sur la voie publique mais c'est
bien sûr le budget de paris me lever 4
qui ai pris la partie sécurité
sur toutes les tous les sites de
compétition notamment en matière de
recherche de partenariat et de
sponsoring
là aussi peut-être vous dire quelques
éléments pour vous dire où on en est sûr
notre objectif ça pèse quand même pour
un tiers de notre budget aujourd'hui
pour paris 2024 on a à la fin de l'année
2020 sécurisé 53% de ce cet objectif
on est dans les mêmes temps de passage
que londres 2012 à la même période qui
était pour nous bon très très
concrètement un peu la référence sur
laquelle on s'est basés donc pour
l'instant
indépendamment de la crise on a suivi le
même rythme de signature de partenariats
qu'avant qu'avant la crise et notre
objectif serait de sécuriser à peu près
deux tiers de nos revenus à la fin de
l'année 2021 pour garder la même vitesse
d'avancement
indépendamment de la crise c'est
vraiment l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé
avec les équipes de paris 2024 de
continuer à avancer
indépendamment du contexte économique
actuel pour l'instant on continue
d'avancer dans les négociations avec un
certaines entreprises qui restent
intéressés parce que vous l'avez vu tout
à l'heure c'est je reste malgré tout une
plateforme de communication assez unique
et très attractives et donc aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de signal d' alerte sur
notre programme marketing de recherche
de partenariats on continue d'avancer
selon les prévisions initiales
voilà je crois pour les quelques
éléments de réponse vous êtes nombreux à
vous être inscrits donc je vais vous
donner la parole vous demandant les uns
et les autres d'être synthétique pour
que chacun puisse exprimer puis surtout
que pour que nous puissions entendre les
réponses de nos invités on va commencer
par michel ça va merci monsieur le
président dont le président chantonnay
monsieur le directeur général mesdames
et messieurs chers collègues je vous
nous avez donc présenté un petit peu
aujourd'hui l'état des lieux de
l'organisation de cette grande
manifestation sportive que doit
organiser notre pays alors on voit bien
qu'il ya deux piliers il ya
l'organisation tout d'abord qui sur
lesquels on on peut avoir toutes les
garanties avec l'équipe qui est en place
et la france a démontré ces dernières
années qu'elle était en capacité
d'organiser les grandes manifestations
sportives
il est vrai qu'on a besoin de la
mobilisation de tous et et c'est sur ce
point que je reviendrai ce pape sur mes
questions il est vrai aussi que c'est un
enjeu au niveau national et vous l'avez
fait remarquer de te mettre en valeur
des sites symboliques 1 qui vont montrer
l'excellence de notre pays ça c'est
ainsi c'est un quelque chose de nouveau
dans l'organisation de jeux olympiques
et paralympiques de d'associer le sport
avec la culture mais aussi avec une
économie qui forte en france le tourisme
les images qui vont être diffusées dans
le monde entier vont mettre en valeur
ces sites qui sont extraordinaires et
qui vont donc amener une plus value pour
notre pays
par contre moi je l'autre point qui est
important donc l'organisation jeu pas de
souci l'autre point c'est ce qu'à un des
défis qu'a souligné tony estanguet c'est
l'héritage je crois que nous comme élu
notre responsabilité pour essayer
d'accompagner le pour accompagner
l'organisation des jeux olympiques c'est
sûr mobilisés sur l'héritage sert
comment pendant ces trois ans le pouvoir
politique peut accompagner
l'organisation ces jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour avoir comme seul
objectif qu'à l'issue de ces jeux
olympiques et paralympiques les français
puissent plus pratiquer l'activité
physique et sportive que le sport
retrouve une vraie place dans la société
qui malheureusement ne à pau n'a pas
aujourd'hui on le sait notre nation
n'est pas une nation sportive on en a
fait tout ce constat donc voilà lequel
enjeu prioritaire pour nous politiques
et quand je dis nous c'est le parlement
mais c'est surtout aussi le gouvernement
et du ministère qui doivent mettre les
actions en place pour développer ces
ses activités sur je vais poser donc mes
questions 1 direction du club mais aussi
de solides et aux seins sur le cojep
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui sur sur vous
et là sur terre de jeu et sur génération
de 1024 vous en avait parlé
l'opération des trente minutes on sent
je vous le dis le ressenti qu'on a un
peu aujourd'hui sur le terrain qui a il
ya eu un élan au départ sur terre de jeu
et on sent qu'il ya un petit
ralentissement qui se fait alors c'est
vrai que la conjoncture
la situation sanitaire ne favorise pas
mais je sens qui a besoin de se relancer
l'opération auprès des collectivités
parce qu'il ya eu encore une fois un bon
démarrage et puis là on sent qu'il ya un
petit peu un peu du surplace
maintenant vous avez bien avant
l'opération de 30 minutes que nous avons
collectivement a appelée de nos voeux
depuis longtemps au sénat
là aussi lorsqu'on est sur le terrain
commence élus sur le terrain de ce que
nous allons rencontrer les maires et les
enseignants je pense qu'il ya vraiment
un manque d'information parce que
beaucoup d'enseignants ne connaissent
pas encore le l'opération des trente
minutes
je pense qu'il faut
il est important de mobiliser le
ministère de l'éducation nationale pour
qu'ils encouragent
sur l'ensemble du territoire la mise en
place de cette action lorsque ces des
élus qui vont rencontrer l'éducation
nationale il ya toujours encore mieux
que ce que vient où on vient faire un
peu dans l'organisation même de
l'éducation nationale je crois donc que
l'éducation nationale le ministère doit
faire un effort de communication de
sensibilisation des enseignants parce
qu'encore trop sont trop nombreux à ne
pas avoir connaissance de ce dispositif
sur sur le cojep jour il y a toujours
sur l'organisation une charte du
volontariat olympiques et paralympiques
qui doit être présenté normalement au
1er janvier prochain
pouvez vous nous dire où en sont les
travaux parce que doit aussi c'est
important sur des milliers de bénévoles
qui vont être mobilisés de volontaires
qui vont être mobilisés donc où on est
cette réflexion concernant le
financement on entendu tony estanguet
nous dire que concernant l'organisation
et à 53% des cris des financements des
privés qui étaient pour l'instant obtenu
on entend que l'objectif des deux tiers
pour l'année fin 2002 21 serait bien
entendre aussi la soli deo qui qui a
aussi une groupe une forte participation
du financement privé 1 7 milliard
d'euros savoir où on est le financement
des privés concernant la sole idéaux
alors c'est vrai que la solide et aux
amis en avant et je crois que c'est
aussi un des objectifs de cette
organisation des enjeux urbains
l'horizon 2020 2050 sur le post carbone
la biodiversité sur le climat mais aussi
sur les enjeux sociétaux sociétaux avec
des ambitions sociale d'insertion et
donc tout ça ça c'est des sujets qui a
kid a apparemment n'étaient pas pris en
compte dans l'organisation de grands
événements là aussi c'est il faut que
les collectivités l'état puis ce bien
sûr il participait encore un point sur
la solide et haut en terme de calendrier
où en sommes-nous des travaux concernant
les transports qui sont un élément
important sur en termes d'organisation
de ces jeux olympiques
aussi bien pour les athlètes que pour la
presse les médias et le grand public qui
va venir participer à ces jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
voilà monsieur le président et on va
prendre
des questions comme ça vous aurez une
vue d'ensemble de cairns merci monsieur
le président alors monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur général merci pour
votre présentation pour votre présence
ce matin je ne vais pas revenir sur
l'héritage qui a été largement abordée
par jean jacques et michel
mais je voudrais parler d'eux
voudrais vous poser plusieurs questions
notamment en ce qui concerne le
financement on a abordé la partie par ce
partenariat
mais une autre partie qui concerne un
tiers des recettes c'est la billetterie
alors là aussi il ya une question qui se
pose est ce que il y aura encore d'ici
là la problématique sanitaire en pouvant
accueillir moins voire pas du tout de
public
donc là aussi il faut trouver des
financements complémentaires
je pense qu'il ne s'agit pas forcément
d'augmenter le prix du billet parce que
là on n'est pas forcément gagnant
ensuite vous avez parlé de
très rapidement de l'organisation
territoriale puisque les jeux olympiques
ce n'est pas que paris 2024 ce sont les
jeux olympiques pour la france donc
qu'en est il des de la répartition qui
avait été évoqué un moment donné
notamment pour les entraînements des
matches de foot et outre et puis moi je
voulais souligner votre approche en
disant que tout sportif de haut niveau
tout sportif professionnel vient est
issu d'une petite structure associative
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
mais je pense que notre ministre n'a pas
encore compris ceux ci se c'était juste
une petite anecdote
après au niveau au niveau de la soli deo
j'ai noté avec satisfaction que qui a
encore du temps donc pas besoin
d'accélérer c'est très bien mais comme
michel je voudrais aborder également le
problème des transports de
l'accessibilité donc qu'en est il des
infrastructures routières ferroviaires
qui était prévu en ce qui concerne leur
construction et leur extension
je ne vais pas être plus long thomas
dessus oui merci merci monsieur le
président et merci pour cette
présentation alors évidemment on va
salué l'ambition écologique des jeux le
fait que la sobriété soit le maître mot
sa marque même un grand changement pour
les grands événements sportifs donc
évidemment c'est à saluer vous l'avez
dit on veut des jeux plus sobre chaque
euro dépensé doit avoir un impact
écologique important et dans le même
temps vous avez dit aussi que les jo
était la plus grosse plateforme de
communication mondial et on a vu la
place des partenaires privés dans le
modèle économique
un tiers du budget c'est énorme et donc
pour les satisfaire
beaucoup de dérogations ont été
accordées en matière de publicité
notamment sur les lieux avoir tout à
forte valeur patrimoniale
vous avez vous avez rappelé le aussi
l'intérêt de mettre en avant notre
patrimoine à travers les jeux mais avec
ces dérogations
on peut se poser la question de la
présence publicitaire sur des lieux à
forte valeur patrimoniale notamment en
termes de grandes bâches ou de grands
écrans numériques donc c'est une
question c'est les dérogations le
permettent
est-ce que c'est envisager aussi dans le
partenariat privé la place de ces
publicités dans des lieux classés et
puis pour revenir sur les partenaires
vous avez un des partenaires historiques
des jo et qui a resigné jusqu'en 2032
qui est coca cola mais qui est désigné
aussi comme le premier pollueur
plastique mondiale est-ce que
les ses partenaires profiteront de ces
jo et de cette ambition écologique pour
s'aligner un peu sur des objectifs tels
que les vôtres est ce qu'il ya des
engagements des annonceurs là dedans au
delà du greenwashing habituel de ses
grandes marques
voilà mes questions merci monsieur le
président bonjour monsieur le président
bonjour monsieur le recteur au jour
madame chers collègues je suis désolé je
vais être de nouveau extrêmement
vulgaire et et trivial et vous parlez
des transports parce que un petit souci
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
point entre ce qui était prévu par le
dossier de candidature et ce qui est
réalisable étant entendu que dans le
réalisable
il ya évidemment tout ce qui porte sur
le charles de gaulle express et la
possibilité de mener à bien ce projet
nous avions reçu le 9 décembre 2020 le
préfet cadot qui nous avait dit que il y
avait des retards qui était qui était
évident notamment sur la il cesse
jusqu'à la gare rer du bourget et je le
cite le retard accumulé n'est pas
complètement irrattrapable donc est ce
qu il a pu être rattrapé est ce que est
ce qu'il est ce qu'il est rattrapable
entre temps il ya eu d'autres soucis
moi je suis usagers de la ligne b du rer
l'avenir s'assombrit et j'insiste parce
que mes collègues ne vivent pas à paris
et parfois je les envie imagine que le
problème des transports c'est surtout de
se déplacer pour les sportifs et les
spectateurs d'un cipra l'autre mais
pendant les jeux olympiques nouveau on
doit continuer à vivre et aujourd'hui
[Musique]
l'acceptabilité des jeux olympiques pour
les futures villes candidates c'est
quelque chose de déterminant si vous
avez une dégradation des conditions de
vie quotidienne
deux des personnes qui vivent en région
parisienne à la suite des jeux vous
aurez de plus en plus en plus de mal à
trouver des candidatures donc moi
j'aimerais que vous nous fassiez un
point je sais très bien qu'il ya
beaucoup de d'hypothèses que je viens
d'évoquer qui ne sont pas sous votre
responsabilité qui dépendent d'autres
d'autres centres de décision c'est ce
qui fait toute la complexité ceux de
ceux de ce dossier je le comprends
parfaitement mais à un moment donné on a
besoin de faire un bilan général et je
crois que vous êtes en capacité de le
faire
merci monsieur le président catherine
dumas merci monsieur le président
monsieur le président madame monsieur
merci pour cette présentation qui était
très clair moi j'étais particulièrement
intéressés par ce que vous avez dit à
propos des territoires c'est vrai que
les jeux sont une chance pour tous nos
territoires
la mise en valeur du patrimoine je suis
élu de paris et notamment le
développement métropolitain ça
m'intéresse particulièrement
alors je voudrais revenir sur deux
points ce qui a été évoqué les 30
minutes de sport le sport à l'école
c'est évoqué par mon collègue savin et
il est évident et madame vous l'avez dit
que ce n'est pas respecté par tout
d'abord je pense aussi qu'il ya un
défaut de communication
et puis avec des pratiques différentes
selon les territoires en ce qui concerne
le territoire parisien
on voit bien que nous avons un déficit
je voudrais savoir à ce propos
qu'est ce qu'il en est de cette semaine
olympique dans les écoles qui a dû se
dérouler du 1er au 6 février
voir donc un certain nombre
d'informations pour savoir si c'est un
outil qui a pu aller dans le bon sens et
ma deuxième question porte monsieur le
président sur le club paris 2024 que
vous avez évoquées il me semble que
c'est une initiative très intéressante
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus savoir avoir un retour
d'impressions autour de ce club
huit mois après sa mise en service je
crois qui en fait a pour ambition de
donner aux français elle envie de se
passionner pour cet événement qu'en est
il exactement
merci beaucoup merci président merci
monsieur le président si le directeur
puis dams et messieurs moi je j'ai
plusieurs questions à la première
question c'est s'il y a j'ai cru
comprendre sur deux de resserrement
budgétaire est ce que ça peut avoir une
a dit une incidence sur l'héritage
tendre en infrastructures en structure
et puis surtout sur les retombées
culturelles sociales
la deuxième question c'est est ce que
vous avez prévu un plan e comme
estanguet sur la pandémie
pourrait-il d'abord une pandémie 2024 et
là je rejoins le coquen sur les 3
milliards 9,1 milliards 3 en billetterie
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya certainement
une vraie question
la troisième nous sommes en train de
travailler sur les respect des principes
de la république
notre cher collègue ses fans biennois
rapporteur c'était une occasion
inespérée exceptionnelle pour la france
pour faire nation pour faire ce gros
mais ce sentiment d'appartenir à un même
pays de pouvoir y participer est ce que
vous avez réfléchi et comment vous
pouvez agir en ce sens pour pour pour
faire adhérer à tous nos jeunes à toute
la jeunesse il ya toute la france ses
valeurs de la république
et puis enfin une question peut-être
plus plus techniques sur les appels à
concurrence moi j'ai été interpellé par
des fédérations parce que les appels à
conclure en sont proposés par équipement
sur l'organisation générale ce qu'on
appelle les lois et par discipline pour
l'organisation sportive les lobé lobé
qu'on appelle et les associations qui
sont les fédérations internationales et
nationales elles doivent
donc posé leur candidature et ce sont
les fédérations internationales
d'ailleurs je crois qu'ils sont
également conseils pour les entreprises
d'après ce que j'ai compris c'est
quelque chose d'un peu de technique
bon si c'est aujourd'hui c'est difficile
à y répondre
bon je vous répondrai par la suite mais
ça veut dire qu'à un moment donné les
fédérations et les s'interroge sur le
conflit d'intérêts qu'il peut y avoir
entre les fédérations internationales
qui sont pros cei en même temps les
fédérations nationales qui qui postulent
merci céline boulay espère odier oui
merci monsieur le président merci à tous
pour cette présentation exhaustive et
intéressante
moi j'suis sénatrice de paris il y
aurait beaucoup de questions à poser par
rapport à la capitale et moi j'ai un
regret pour reprendre un peu les termes
de ma collègue catherine dumas c'est que
pendant que le projet des jo dont tout
le monde s'accorde à dire qu'il est
extrêmement important pour paris pour la
france et dans le cas d'un plan de
relance et après cette pandémie n'est
pas été assortie d'un projet plus
ambitieux de la part du président la
république sur le grand paris dans une
ville qui est enserré aujourd'hui d'un
périphérique un peu thrombose et en 3d
beaucoup de travaux et autant on a parlé
grands projets on a par l'héritage
héritage durable etc etc
autant on n'a pas beaucoup parlé des
parisiens dans cette présentation et
j'espère que tous les niveaux ils seront
associés consulter parce que s'il ya une
grande fierté et de la part des
parisiens que nous sommes en priorité
bien sûr autour de ces projets il y a
aussi beaucoup d'inquiétudes et donc moi
j'ai trois questions la première elle
concerner les partenariats public-privé
et la recherche de partenaires qui selon
madame hidalgo doit s'accélérer à partir
du mois d'août michel savin a posé la
question et je pense que vous allez vous
allez répondre
la deuxième c'était concernant la
sécurité qui est une préoccupation
majeure des parisiens dans le contexte
incertain actuel que nous connaissons et
vous avez évoqué une augmentation de 30
mille euros du budget de la sécurité
je voulais savoir les pistes qui était
envisagé par exemple l'utilisation de
drones ou ce genre de choses et puis la
troisième question est concerné les
trente deux chantiers que vous avez
évoqué en décembre 2021 est ce qu'on
peut avoir un peu plus de précision là
dessus et enfin quatrièmement vous dites
vouloir associer le sport et la culture
qui sont deux secteurs qui sont
extrêmement malmené dans cette pandémie
je pensais notamment au grand palais je
voulais savoir si vous pouviez
développer un peu ce point là et puis
toute dernière question si je suis pas
trop longue
le projet de verdissement de la tour
eiffel de tout ce secteur qui va aller
de la tour eiffel en passant par le
champ de mars jusqu'au champs elysées il
ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes de la part des
élus locaux et des français et des
parisiens là dessus est ce que vous
pourriez m'en dire un mot merci c'était
pas le couloir merci monsieur le
président ce président est engagé le
directeur général merci pour ce point
d'étape qui est toujours un important
pour la commission de la culture et
communication et du sport j'ai pour
rebondir un petit peu sur les propos du
du rapporteur jean jacques lozach tout à
l'heure je veux dire que quand même ce
qu'on le on ne le dit pas suffisamment 7
c'est une occasion unique de valoriser
le sport sur notre dans notre pays
les jeux olympiques je pense que nous
serons la seule expérience que nous
vivrons en ce qui nous concerne
probablement on a cette chance de
pouvoir la vivre
espérons en tout cas l'an dans trois ans
il faut vraiment qu'on s'empare de cette
de cette opportunité bien sûr il ya eu
cette initiative avec terre des jeux ça
a démarré très fort michel savart l'a
dit tout à l'heure les collectivités
dans tous les départements se sont
saisis de cette opportunité
ça a démarré très fort aujourd'hui on
constate que c'est francis dire à
l'arrêt c'est normal il y aussi des
circonstances qui font que mais ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il ya un
enthousiasme qui doit naître au niveau 2
au niveau du grand public tout
simplement il faudrait embarqué madame
l'a dit tout à l'heure pour les jeunes
enfants des pratiques dès le plus jeune
âge qui contribue d'ailleurs à une santé
mentale une attention d'ailleurs dans
les classes qui est absolument
incontestable et c'est le sait l'ancien
enseignant qui peut vous le dire aussi
il ya un public qui qui mérite d'être
visé spécifiquement qu'il l'a été avec
la définition du label génération de
1024 puisque c'est le ministère sont les
ministères de l'enseignement supérieur
et du sport qui se sont mis autour de la
table pour définir cette ce label qui a
qui veut soutenir le développement la
pratique sportive y compris pour les
étudiants et on sait à quel point les
étudiants soient aujourd'hui
dans une situation de souffrance bien
sûr du fait de la des cours à distance
souffrance psychologique une stature
totalement de cette sédentarité qu'on
leur impose avec des courants distanti
elle est arrivée à 18 heures hé bien ou
19h le couvre-feu leur impose à nouveau
restés chez eux ça il ya vraiment une
un manque qui est en train de se créer
avec des risques de deux liés à la
sédentarité des risques de santé tout
court est ce que vous pouvez faire un
petit point d'étape sur le nombre
d'établissements du supérieur qui ont
adhéré à cet assaut label qui se sont
inscrits dans cette dynamique où on est
c'est dynamique dans les universités
dans les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur deuxième question sur la
sobriété la sobriété écologique et
énergétique moi j'observe que alors je
crois que les précédents jeux d'été ont
émis 3,5 millions de tonnes de co2
l'objectif est de diviser par 2 même un
peu plus puisque l'objectif est de 1.5
millions de tonnes de co2 il faut être
clair il n'y a pas de manifestation et
d'organisation de ce type qui ne génère
pas de co2 on est dans un pays où on a
tendance à vouloir faire laver plus
blanc que blanc c'est pas c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
évidemment que cet enthousiasme que
cette opportunité que je cible est toute
à l'heure et mais d aimer des du carbone
néanmoins il ya vraiment une volonté
forte en divisant par deux monsieur le
directeur général l'a dit tout à l'heure
- 45 % pour les constructions de sites
ma question être sur l'origine des de
l'énergie qui va alimenter les
différents sites pour vous savez on a un
débat régulier ici au sénat sur escaut
le nucléaire par exemple est une origine
une énergie décarbonée
la réponse est oui même s'il ya d'autres
d'autres sujets est ce que vous avez une
stratégie une politique en termes
d'approvisionnement l'énergie
l'électricité par exemple garantie des
carbo des avec les fournisseurs
d'énergie traditionnelles merci et enfin
les clients
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le directeur général
mesdames
mesdames et messieurs donc beaucoup de
questions et proposer donc je vais être
assez rapide
vous avez énoncé un certain nombre
d'objectifs qui sont évidemment que nous
partageons sur l'organisation de ces
jeux moi alors je vais avoir trois
petites questions sur l'impact de la
crise sanitaire vous avez bien entendu
dit que les collectivités étaient partie
prenante dans l'organisation dans les
travaux pour ces jeux donc avez vous à
ce stade des craintes sur leurs
capacités à tenir le calendrier parce
qu'on sait la pandémie la pandémie a
impacté de manière très importante à la
fois leur capacité financière leur
fonctionnement capacité à investir il
leur leur budget de fonctionnement
avez vous des craintes par rapport aux
la réactivité des collectivités par
rapport à ce calendrier sur lequel vous
avez dit que vous aviez encore un petit
peu de de temps et de marche sur les
objectifs les 30 minutes des 3 millions
de pratiquement pratiquant par don
supplémentaire alors sur ces 30 minutes
je rejoins mon collègue je pense que
l'application est à géométrie variable
dans les territoires dans les
établissements donc y at-il quelque
chose d'imaginer afin de mettre en place
de manière rigoureuse dans tous les
établissements et aussi de contrôler
cette cette application est ce que les
30 minutes
est ce que c'est juste on affiche qu'on
veut 30 minutes
ou est ce qu'on aura véritablement une
mise en place tout à fait sérieuse est
obligatoire avec un contrôle derrière
ensuite sur les 3 millions de
pratiquants
nous connaissons tous dans nos
collectivités aujourd'hui un
désengagement dans les associations un
désengagement des bénévoles notamment
parce que évidemment la pandémie éloigne
les pratiquants de leur pratique
sportive et de leur club
donc avez vous mesurer cet impact sur la
possibilité de
deux bénévoles de s'engager au niveau
des jeux est ce que ce sera quelque
chose qui peut être à craindre et
dernière question puisque nous avions
des débats encore hier soir assez tard
dans la nuit avec les relais respect le
respect des principes de la république
donc qu'en est-il de l'égalité hommes
femmes puisque vous aviez afficher un
certain nombre d'objectifs très vertueux
donc qu'en est-il de l'égalité homme
femme et du respect de la charte
olympique puisque nous avons eu des
débats longs sur la neutralité et donc
vous aurez compris que hier il était
question notamment de deux sujets qui
étaient assez clivant pour l'hémicycle
et c'est par exemple voile par exemple
seulement
et enfin dernière question pour
catherine morin desailly merci
présidente d'abord féliciter les équipes
pour leur résilience parce que dans un
contexte actuel tel que la crise
sanitaire anticipé ça va préparer les
jeux olympiques c'est fort compliqué
donc bravo ma question sera extrêmement
simple et courte
la france organisera si tout va bien les
gymnasiades en 2022 en normandie si les
plans de financement bien sûr sont vos
clés donc tout cela porté par l'urss
quel est le lien structurel aux jeux
olympiques 2024 pouvez vous nous
expliquer comment vous capital élevées
sur l'avenue tous ces jeunes venus du
monde entier être compétiteur pour
justement donné une dimension très forte
aux jeux olympiques 2000 le 24 je
remercie de votre réponse
voilà je vais vous laisser maintenant on
pourrait partir les réponses je ne sais
pas qui commence
qui étire le premier alors je vous en
prie monsieur le directeur
alors j'ai quelques réponses puisque
l'essentiel et c'est assez naturellement
aux homos cojo je vais les monterrat
devait prendre dans l'ordre dans lequel
vous nous avez posé comme ça monsieur
vous me posiez la question sur des
années les fonds privés par année les
milliards 7 de fonds privés alors que je
vous explique le milliard sept ne passe
pas par la seule idéaux mais pour
construire l'ensemble des objets
nécessaires pour les jeux et un certain
nombre de bâtiments qui sont des
bâtiments d'habitation qui sont
construits par des promoteurs privés
loués par le cojo pendant les jeux après
les jeux rendu par le cos jours ont fait
quelques travaux à l'intérieur pour
transformer en gros des chambres
d'étudiants qui vont accueillir les
athlètes en appartements familiaux en
hôtel en bureau donc ensuite ça passe à
vis à vis de bâtiments normaux avec des
utilisateurs finaux l'ensemble de ces
investissements donc privé qui ne
transite pas par pas par la suite et au
total est d'à peu près un milliard sept
aujourd'hui nous avons contractualisé
avec les promoteurs pour qu'il fasse sur
l'intégralité de ce programme d'un
milliard sept
c'est sécurisé à l'exception d'un
bâtiment qui a vocation après les jeux
être du bureau qui pour lequel le
financement de ce bâtiment là est encore
en discussions avec l'investisseur final
qui donc est rude le récupèrera le
bâtiment en 2025
donc on a sur le milliard sept cette
incertitude qui représente à peu près de
150 millions d'euros qui n'est pas une
certitude de fonds publics
il faut que le promoteur avec lequel on
a contractualisé finissent la
négociation avec l'investisseur final
est preneur finale sur tout le reste
on est dans un processus qui est
sécurisée sur les recettes
alors ensuite vous avez été plusieurs
monsieur ça va hein monsieur kern à
monsieur ouzoulias s'excuser mois à
m'interroger sur les transports
bon alors d'abord je dois être
extrêmement humble là-dessus la soli deo
ne portent les sujets d'investissement
routier mais la décision du gouvernement
dès 2017 afin d'aider début 2018 a été
dire tout ce qui est investissement dans
les transports collectifs n'ai pas
piloté suivis accompagnés par la seule
vidéo mais directement par la délégation
interministérielle aux jeux nous fait
que vous ayez reçu monsieur le préfet
cadot me dis-je hop actuel au mois de
janvier
donc je vais être assez succinct sur la
partie transport collectif auquel j'ai
pas grand chose à dire d'autre que ce
que je lis dans la presse et du coup je
suis moins bien informés que vous autant
pardon donc sur la partie route
je vous plais jours ouvrés ou dire trois
choses que je sais sur les transports en
commun mais c'est je sais c'est
plusieurs alors soit partie routière
soit partie routière on nous avons un
programme d' équipes d'investissement
pour ce qu'on appelle les voies
olympiques qui sont des investissements
sur les routes donc d'équipement pérenne
qui permette pendant les jeux à la
l'ensemble de la grande famille
olympique de garantir ces temps de
transport et qui après les jeux vont
améliorer un certain nombre d' un
certain fonctionnement du réseau routier
donc il y en a sur les autoroutes mais
il y en a sur le périphérique
aujourd'hui donc à la fois a réalisé par
l'état et par la ville de paris c'est
beaucoup de systèmes de vidéo
verbalisation donc de caméras
d'améliorations ponctuelles de
l'infrastructure y en a frappé 37
millions d'euros
donc ça ce second tour on touche 90 km
je vous dis le chiffre de tête 90 km in
her donc sur les grandes infrastructures
structurantes de l'ile-de-france ce
programme là il est stabilisé
on est dans la phase de finir les
conceptions pour rentrer en travaux ça a
fait partie des différents chantiers
dont je parlerai tout à l'heure pour
madame boulet
il ya un deuxième volet de transport
routier mais qui est ce qu'on appelle le
dernier kilomètre c'est une fois vous
sortez du périphérique comment est ce
que vous allez jusqu'à bercy que comment
est ce que vous sortez la trêve pour
aller jusqu à elancourt et c'est donc
cette question du dernier kilomètre et
des petits aménagements qu'il faut faire
entre l'infrastructure structurantes et
le site de compétition voir si ce sont
des aménagements qui ont vocation à
rester pérenne donc être financée par la
sto l'ideo ou si c'est simplement des
aménagements provisoires qu'on met en
place pour les jeux est donc mis en
place par le cojo ce travail là il
débute maintenant
mais on est sur des petites choses c est
ce qu il faut refaire un carrefour parce
que les quarts ou les équipements
peuvent pas tourner oui c'est ce genre
de choses moi donc il débute et là aussi
ça permettra de fluidifier le système
troisième remarque toujours sur les
transports on aime qu'est la question du
vélo et du développement du vélo qui
n'était pas du tout une problématique au
début de l'histoire de la soul idéaux
qui depuis un an que ça veut tout c est
un sujet qui pour le moment est un sujet
qui est portée à la fois août pour nous
par la région ile de france et par la
ville de paris et dans lequel on a une
question collective de savoir quelle
place on donne aux vélos et
singulièrement pour le déplacement des
spectateurs sachant que le vélo ce que
la question n'est pas tellement la voie
cyclable mais c'est l'endroit où on
accroche son vélo à la fin voilà et donc
c'est ça la difficulté que nous avons si
on dit que 5 ou 10 % des spectateurs
viennent en vélo qu'il faut des grands
parkings à vélo comme tels qu'ils
existent en hollande et où est-ce qu'on
l'aimé et effectivement dans la phase de
conception aujourd'hui on n'a pas
intégré des parkings à vélos de de cette
taille là donc c'est un sujet en face de
nous et troisième dimension enfin sur la
question des déplacements je répondrais
je dire un mot sur les transports
collectifs c'est la question la
démonstration des savoir faire
il ya aujourd'hui ne
un débat pour savoir si on lit on pousse
ou pas l'hydrogène est donc pour moi au
niveau d investissement pérenne ça pose
la question est ce que on est rompue
n'en sont qu'aux finances on accompagne
le financement de stations de recharge
d'hydrogène ou pas ça dépend aussi de la
manière dans le cojo va avoir besoin ou
pas d'hydrogène pour ses propres son
propre système de transport et de la
volonté des élus derrière de développer
le l'hydrogène sur son territoire donc
ça c'est un des sujets mais vous voyez
dépôt de mettre en place une station
hydrogène à mesure on a trois ans devant
nous on sait faire on accepte c'est pas
un projet dure mais voila voila c'est
les trois dimensions donc les voies
routières les gros sujets sont étudiées
maintenant 9 km le vélo et l'hydrogène
au titre de l'innovation la
démonstration d'un à savoir faire enfin
soit transports collectifs écoutez moi
je sais pas je sais pas quoi vous dire
de plus que ce que tu roules et oui la
ligne 16 on est inquiet sur la capacité
de jean 16 à aller jusqu'au bourget j'ai
pas d'éléments plus récent que ce que le
préfet cadot vous a dit au mois de
janvier là dessus sur la ligne 14
ce que moi j'entends y compris côté ratp
c'est que la desserte d'orly pour 2024
la ratp assurée là dessus et donc la n
14 de pleyel à orly a priori on devrait
y arriver
donc il ya plus d'un an cette espèce
d'inquiétude la tendre on a pu avoir ça
pas dire c'est facile mais c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on devrait y arriver et
la structuration du pôle pleyel devrait
devrait être achevé pour les jeux sur
cdg express et le link b du rer là je
mets un joker complet je me lâche je ne
sais pas du tout vous répondre là dessus
ensuite
j'avais une question sur l'incidence de
l'héritage qu'ils aient des problèmes
financiers
l'incident sur l'héritage matériel s'il
ya des problèmes financiers alors trois
remarques très rapidement la première
remarque c'est que l'ensemble de la
maquette de la stvi des eaux a été re
délibéré à notre conseil
d'administration d'octobre 2002 20 donc
il ya quatre mois et l'ensemble des
cofinanceurs s'est repositionnée
favorablement sur l'ensemble de la
maquette donc sur un apport d'un
milliard 386 millions d'euros en euro
donc aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
d'inquiétudes sur les problèmes
financiers les apports publics au
conseil d'administration du mois de mars
dernier les ensembles des cofinanceurs a
délibéré sur les principes d'indexation
comment est-ce qu'on passe d euro 2016
en euros courants donc délibération de
méthodes et principes qui va être suivi
d'une série de délibérations au mois de
juillet puis à l'automne de mise en
oeuvre que financeur par cofinanceurs
donc pour le moment je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude est donc cette question
2 est ce qu on diminuerait d'héritage
matériel c'est les problèmes financiers
je ne n'ai pas d'alert là dessus
voilà ensuite sur la question des
chantiers madame la sénatrice et
notamment des chantiers à paris les 30
de chantier alors on a trente deux
objets en chantier qu'est ce qui va être
en chantier
globalement c'est les travaux objet 1
c'est le village olympique
c'est le village et journalistes c'est
la piscine olympique en face du stade de
france
le seao c'est évidemment la reine à deux
bords de la chapelle oui et donc toute
l'opération autour de la porte de la
chapelle avec ba qui est déjà en
chantier aujourd'hui avec la destruction
de trucs de bling bling de bain un
parking un bowling donc c'est déjà en
chantier ça sera en chantier de
construction à ce moment là mais à paris
c'est tout ce qu'on strikes le sait tous
ce sera en chantier à la fin de l'année
concernant les besoins spécifiques des
jeux le reste des gros chantiers sont
plutôt dans le genre en
seine-saint-denis avec des groupes
scolaires et puis évidemment yves du
manoir
yves du manoir dans le dans les
hauts-de-seine sur la sobriété que
logique
je n'ai pas grand chose de plus à dire
que ce que je veux que ce que j'avais pu
vous vous dire effectivement on va
atteindre 45% de de baisse des émissions
carbone ce qui est un chiffre qui est
assez inespéré il existe des bâtiments
qui font beaucoup mieux
vous pouvez avoir des bâtiments
descendra soit moins 70 % ce qui est
ainsi ce vraiment là dessus devant vous
parce que c'est ça que c'était extra mer
c'est que sur le village olympique ses
trois cent mille mètres carrés consorts
et donc on est dans des très grands
volumes et le village olympique
autant il ya de l'argent public pour
libérer les terrains pour faire des
ménages et d'entreprises qui étaient là
autant il n'y a pas d'argent public pour
la construction
ce dont je vous parlais monsieur savin
les investisseurs construisent luo cojo
et ensuite trouver des utilisateurs
finals il n'y a pas d'âge de subventions
dedans donc on est dans l'économie de la
seine saint denis on est dans l'économie
de la première couronne parisienne
et il arrive à faire - 45 % aujourd'hui
simplement parce que y'a la dynamique
des jeux parce qu'il ya une forte
volonté politique pour le faire et ça
c'est important parce que ça veut dire
que si on le fait on est capable de le
faire sans subventions publiques en
seine-saint-denis aujourd'hui on peut le
faire dans toutes les préfectures de
france aujourd'hui au moins dans toutes
les grandes métropoles
française et donc dès aujourd'hui on
peut atteindre le moins 45% de carbone
sur des grands volumes c'est ça ce qu'on
démontre
après on peut aller bien au delà mais
sur des petits bâtiments de 2,3 mètres
carrés qui sont des bâtiments sur lequel
on teste des choses là on passe à
l'échelle et puis madame millions sur le
sur le l'impact de la crise sanitaire
alors le premier confinement de tout
premier il ya un an il effectivement
nous a un peu tous pris par surprise et
toutes les collectivités où l'état
n'était pas nécessairement préparés à
télétravailler on va pas et d'ailleurs
la soli deo à avait des il se trouve
qu'on avait des réserves d'ordinateurs
parce qu'on avait passé un gros marché
en prévision de notre croissance des
effectifs et donc on a prêté des
ordinateurs alors non pas aux
collectivités mais à l'état pour qu'il
puisse continuer à travailler chez eux
honnêtement on a ce qu'on a constaté
c'est que depuis l'été la pratique du du
travail à distance
c'est sur nos sujets sur nos sujets
généraliser partout tant aux côtés et
tacle côté collectivités et donc
lorsqu'on a eu le deuxième confinement à
l'automne on n'a pas eu de viscosité
particulière dans la conduite de nos
opérations
je peux pas en dire beaucoup plus sur le
sur le parti est la partie humaine donc
on va voir maintenant comment ça se
passe mais on est on est assez serein
est un grand air mais enfin bon on n'est
pas inquiet voilà ton juste comme ça
soit partie financière je ne peux que
vous redire ce que je vous le disais
tout à l'heure à savoir que les
collectivités ont revoté au mois
d'octobre sur leur contribution
on revotait au mois de mars 2021 sur le
principe d'indexation donc de peu pour
passer de re 2016 ans en euros courants
et la dernière discussion sur le plan
financier qu'il ya entre co financeurs
c'est finalement dans l'ensemble des
financements de la soul idéaux nous
avions mis de côté en 2018
une réserve de 100 millions d'euros pour
faire face aux nouveaux objets vois pas
ce qu on en réfère début 2018 on savait
pas encore le programme complet
et donc sur ces nouveaux objets on a pu
le dire qu'on finance est le site des
scats pérenne qui n'était pas prévu au
début où la base de plus et c est le
dernier débat entre cofinanceurs c'est
comment est ce que il utilise cette
réserve
entre les nouveaux objets les évolutions
de programme et ce qu'on garde pour la
suite de lait des opérations mais voyez
on est j'ai aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
dallaire demain cofinanceurs disant je
ne serais pas capable de faire face à
mana à mes engagements
voilà monsieur présent je pense avoir
été exhaustif si je ne les paie je m'en
excuse
juste juste un point sur les transports
on comprend bien que ça ne relève pas de
la soli deo notamment pour tout ce qui
est transports en commun néanmoins
romancée vous avez cité le bourget et on
sait que c'est le bourget ne sera pas
desservi par le grand paris express en
malheureusement et s'il ya des
réflexions sur des transports de
substitution qui sont d'ores et déjà
abordé et est ce que ça peut avoir un
impact sur le bilan écologique des jeux
olympiques ça je je ne pleure là je vais
peut-être faire la passe à tony
estanguet parce que voilà parce que
vraiment moi je m'occupe de
l'investissement le le fonctionnement
est jeune et hors de mon champ de
compétence se produire alors peut-être
du coup moi je commence sur ce point
transports
peut-être avant de répondre précisément
à cette question je voudrais juste
repréciser un petit peu la manière avec
laquelle on a travaillé sur les
transports en fait en 2016 quand on
construit un dossier de candidature on
se cale sur la carte du grand paris
express
il n'y a aucune ligne je le répète ici
parce que des fois on peut créer une
petite confusion
aucune ligne de transport qui n'était
demandée par paris 2024 on n'a jamais
demandé quoi que ce soit en matière de
transport on s'est plutôt adapté c'est
les jeux qui se sont adaptés à la carte
des transports de cette région ile de
france pour aller implantés des sites de
compétition là où étaient prévus des
gars là on nous avait garanti qu'il y
aurait des gares et des lignes de
transport et nous avons maintenu un
certain nombre de sites de compétition
notamment en seine-saint-denis
quand il y a deux ans on nous a garanti
que ces lignes serait bien livré en
temps et en heure donc juste rappeler là
dessus que s'il ya des retards de
travaux aujourd'hui il est un peu
difficile d'accuser paris 2024 de ces
retards et dans les délais et dans les
coûts parce que bien évidemment on n'est
absolument pas comme vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs ou aux manettes sur ces
sujets là mais plutôt on est des clients
juste un bon les transports en commun
vont être utilisés pour les spectateurs
nous par 1024 comité d'organisation nous
devons mettre en place un système de
transport pour les personnes accréditées
les athlètes les journalistes les
volontaires pour les le public et les
volontaires pardon les volontaires aussi
vont utiliser les transports en commun
nous nous offrons entre guillemets la
gratuité de ces transports sur notre
budget pour les détenteurs de billets
donc les spectateurs pour qu'ils
puissent utiliser les transports en
commun pour là aussi avoir un impact
carbone et limiter l'empreinte carbone
pour limiter encore une fois les
déplacements en voiture sur sur le
territoire donc sur les transports
alternatifs sur le fait que notamment
les lignes 16 et 17 ne seront pas au
rendez vous on est en train de regarder
les différentes options
avec ile-de-france mobilité avec les
différents partenaires pour voir comment
on peut proposer pour acheminer les
spectateurs il s'agit bien des
spectateurs mais c'est encore une fois
la aux autorités publiques de devoir
mettre en place un système alternatif
puisque il n'est pas dans les
prérogatives de parler de 1024 de
fournir des systèmes de transport pour
acheminer les spectateurs sur les
différentes questions j'en ai un certain
nombre je vais peut-être commencer sur
vos différents points concernant le la
présence de paris 2024 sur les
territoires est ce vous êtes un certain
nombre à avoir mis en avant peut-être le
coup d'arrêt ou en tous les cas le
ralentissement du programme terre de
jeux 2024 dans en présence de territoire
juste là aussi nous paraît 2024 encore
une fois on ne s'est jamais engagé un
nombre quantitatif de nombre de
labellisés
aujourd'hui quand même quelques mois
après le lancement de ce programme
et malgré cette crise sanitaire on a
mille trois cents et quelques communes
labellisées 90 départements presque
toutes les régions
et 25 millions de français qui vivent
dans une commune terre de jeux 2024 des
programmes qui continue à se mettre en
place notamment le provost dernier
programme exploitèrent de jeu qui permet
à toutes ces communes d'identifier des
parcours de pratique sportive sur leur
territoire pour faire découvrir le
patrimoine notamment et on a eu un très
bon taux de participation de tous et
toutes ces collectivités labellisées le
programme des centres de préparation des
jeux qui est lié directement au label
terre de jeu puisque pour pouvoir être
éligible au statut de centre de
préparation des jeux et accueillir des
délégations internationales avant les
jeux il faut d'abord être une terre de
jeux 2024 là dessus on a déjà identifié
624 centre de préparation des jeux sur
l'ensemble du territoire puisque tous
les départements qui ont fait acte de
candidature
on était
retenu avec à minima un centre de
préparation des jeux et il reste encore
quelques opportunités pour les nouveaux
sports les quatre nouveaux sports qui
ont été rajoutés au programme pour
identifier quels seront les centres de
préparation pour ces pour ses différents
sports met donc ce programme est bien
évident on compte sur vous pour faire
toute la communication dire que bien
évidemment il est encore temps de
candidater est encore temps de
s'inscrire nous on va autant que
possible continuer aussi à animer ce
réseau et on organise des webinaires et
le dernier mois j'étais impressionné
puisque on avait quasiment toutes les
collectivités qui étaient connectés on a
battu notre record de visio et en ce
moment on fait beaucoup de visio mai
mais c'est à traverser la belle terre de
jeux 2024 qu'on a eu le plus grand
nombre de connexions
donc ça montre à note de notre point de
vue qui a toujours un enthousiasme et
une envie quand même collective de ces
collectivités sur tout le territoire de
faire partie de l'aventuré des jeux
concernant le programme des trente
minutes mais je vais laisser marie
peut-être vous vous dire un petit peu
plus sur les chiffres sur le nombre
d'établissements le nombre d'élèves qui
ont été impactés moi ce que je peux dire
c'est que quand même j'ai participé à
plusieurs réunions avec les ministres
les recteurs qui ont identifié
maintenant des référents dans les
académies
il ya sans référent 30 minutes qui ont
pour mission de développer ce programme
dans l'ensemble des écoles primaires
nous on pousse un depuis un an pour que
cette expérimentation qui a été
expérimenté dans cette académie puisse
être généralisé le plus tôt possible le
ministre lors de notre dernière réunion
il ya quinze jours de cela s'est exprimé
devant les recteurs et et vise que un
tiers des écoles primaires puissent
puisse mettre en place cette expérience
cette mesure des 30 minutes dès l'année
prochaine
donc c'est un objectif assez ambitieux
mais bien évidemment nous à notre point
de vue enfin de l'autre côté on pousse
peut-être mari quelques chiffres là
dessus mais quelques éléments
d'information on a aussi
convaincu amélie amélie mauresmo de nous
accompagner sur le déploiement de ces
trente minutes pour qu'elle joue un rôle
d'ambassadrice auprès des enseignants
notamment mais aussi des enfants pour
expliquer le bien fondé de cette
démarche et pour la disséminer dans les
territoires donc amélie mauresmo est
très partante
on va tourner très prochainement d'ici
roland garros des vidéos avec elle pour
qu'on puisse faire connaître cette
mesure tony le disait un webinaire avec
les 100 référente aires de jeux et la
semaine prochaine un webinaire avec les
sans référent pendant 30 minutes et la
semaine prochaine avec les référents
terre de jeux à l'occasion desquelles on
va parler que d'éducation que du
programme génération 2024 et et 30
minutes
donc ça pour nous c'est important parce
qu'on cherche à créer les connexions
entre les acteurs donc les collectivités
terre de jeux vont pouvoir contacter les
référentes 30 minutes et vice versa pour
qu'il y ait une
un travail de terrain pour que les
choses se déploie sur le territoire on
est aussi en train de discuter avec
l'éducation nationale sur un
accompagnement aux écoles qui met en
place et 30 minutes avec peut-être un
kit on discute avec la haine s pour
financer ce dispositif bref ce que je
vous dis n'est pas prendre pour argent
comptant parce que les discussions sont
en cours mais c'est pour vous dire que
on met le sujet sur la table qu'on
pousse fort pour que ça se déploie
massivement et que le soufflé ne retombe
pas
[Musique]